I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense I have so many questions about
like the actual training itself that I
have even asked myself like it it's like
Pandora's Box working out and food is
like what works give me the answer
everybody wants the pill I'm using pill
with air quotes around it because
everybody wants to know I just do this
and it'll work so right so like first
and foremost what do you need to do for
weight loss if your goal is to lose that
yes the good bad what is what is right
right energy yep it seem like a mile it
measures the life of something a mile is
a mile whether you're on sand in a
forest in New York miles of mine mmm
it's not like a mile doesn't change it's
like the what's within the mile where
you are mm-hmm it might take longer to
travel in my location where you are but
a mile a mile sitting with a calorie
calorie in broccoli is the same as
calorie and a doughnut because it's just
measuring the energy in the food right
but I ain't looking at the total
calories trying to do it in that right
then you can get a need for how much
energy you're putting in your body right
and what most people who are struggling
to lose weight don't realize is how much
energy they're putting in their body
right and you could totally but 100%
100% nuts
I mean trail mix my ultimate demise
granola and trail mix my ultimate demise
I'm like I can crush a thousand calories
in a second with that stuff because I
mean like I finally measured a serving
of granola that I was eating and I was
like
every three servings at a time which is
like you know 500 calories and I'm like
it's my go to the store and like grab a
handful or go to the pantry and grab a
handful and shove it my mouth like that
was good I'll have another one there's a
couple servings right there
so yes 100% calories and it's like it
gets out of control real fast and fat is
the number one way to Jack it up because
it also astonishes me how many people
don't know how many calories are in a
gram of fat and protein and carbohydrate
and fat has nine calories per gram and
carbohydrates and protein only have four
so for every gram of fat it's double the
calories basically so that's why it goes
so fast calories are met
yeah but protein is met yeah yeah true
yep okay it's the only one bars and fats
don't do that okay everything falls into
place based on your total calories so
it's actually like a year ago I would
have been like I'm doing the work I
swear and I am like you don't know me
but I am an ultra healthy eater like I
don't it again I don't even desire bad
food and I'm like I'm the one that's
putting like eleven adaptogens in my
like one tablespoon of chia seeds made
with water hot water like I mean I'm
like so I get it it's very easy to get
it out of control everything sure no
sure they're not sure if they're like
being busy something they super angry
and defensive which is why it like the
fact that you write you know what it's
back in the calories yep anyone who's
active in everything right dude I agree
like a week just like a couple days or a
week you couldn't you eat mostly the
same things so that's why I did it for
like whenever I was home I would do it
and I was like oh when I'm home or when
I'm on the road now it's so much easier
cuz I'm like I get it like the dude
lokah candy ran don't add fat in my
breakfast and don't snack on fat and
then I'm fine
like I finally learned the techniques
but so okay so you know the value of
protein in my head I'm like is protein a
real thing like is this just like a
manufactured propaganda to sell animal
meat like slaughter some cows because
I've got a little bit of an issue with
slaughtering these days so my vegan
vegan journey has somewhat begun or at
least a more humane journey so that
makes protein difficult by the way real
as in real butt so okay so tell me about
protein like just give me the quick
overview of why like it's a real thing
so you really need protein like anything
you could go to either extreme what are
the bodybuilding community they say like
okay so people what's the what's that
what's the gold standard for how many
protein total body weight so if I were
like 110 pounds how much I should do it
if you're already tells you to water
then big leap for you because you're
already very lean we can use your body
weight right you're already really don't
have extra fat okay so I use your body
weight I would say 100 110 grams would
be great for you you good yeah but if
you have a lot more of a solute you
don't wanna go back total body weight is
no date on them
right okay goalie got it got it got it
look in the mirror dude
you